let's say I have an n-by-n matrix that
looks like this so let me just see if I
can do it in general terms in the first
row and first column and that entry has
a 1 and then everything else the rest of
the n minus 1 rows in that first column
we're all going to be 0 so it's going to
be zeros all the way down to the nth
term and then the second column we have
a 0 in the first component but then in a
1 in the second component and then it
goes zeros all the way down and you keep
doing this in the third row in the third
order let me say third column although
it would have apply to the third row as
well that the one shows up in the third
component and then it's zeros all the
way down and this essentially you have
the ones filling up the diagonal of this
matrix right here so if you go all the
way to the nth column or the nth column
vector you have a bunch of zeros until
you get you have n minus 1 zeros and
then the very last component the nth
component there will be a 1 so you have
essentially a matrix with 1 down ones
down the diagonal this matrix has a
bunch of neat properties and we'll
explore it more in the future but I'm
just exposing you to this because it has
one very neat property relative to
linear transformations but I'm going to
call this the identity matrix and I'll
call this I sub n and I call that sub n
because it's an N by n identity matrix
if I you know I sub 2 would be equal to
a 2 by 2 identity matrix would be it
would look like that and I sub 3 would
look like this 1 0 0 0 1 0 0 0 1 I think
you get the point now the neat thing
about this identity matrix becomes
evident when you multiply it times any
vector so we could we have a default we
can multiply this guy times the N
component vector or a member of RN so
let's do that so if we multiply this
matrix times let's call this vector X
this is X 1 X 2 all the way down to X n
what is this going to be equal to if I
do so this is vector X right here so if
I multiply matrix I my identity matrix I
sub N and I multiply it times my
vector X where X is a member of RN has n
components what am I going to get well
I'm going to get 1 times X 1 plus 0
times X 2 plus 0 times X 3 plus 0 times
X 4 all of that so it's essentially
going to have you can kind of view it as
this row dotted with the vector so
you're the only nonzero term is going to
be the one times the X 1 so it's going
to be X 1 sorry let me do it like this
so you're going to get another vector in
RN you're going to get another vector in
RN like that and so the first term is
that row essentially being dotted with
that column and so you just get X 1 and
then the next the next entry is going to
be this row or you could view it as the
transpose of this row dotted with that
column so 0 times X 1 plus 1 times X 2
plus 0 times everything else so the only
nonzero term is the one times X 2 so you
get an X 2 there and then you keep doing
that and what you're going to get you're
going to get an X 3 because the only
nonzero term here is the third one and
you're going to go all the way down
until you get an xn but what is this
thing equal to this is just equal to X
so the neat thing about this identity
matrix that we've created is that when
you multiply it times any vector you get
the vector again the identity matrix
times any vector in RN it's only defined
for vectors in RN is equal to that
vector again and actually the columns
the columns of the identity matrix have
a special I guess the set of columns has
a set a special name they are called so
you know if we call this first column e1
and this second column e2 and the third
column and the third column let me see e
2 and the third column e 3 and we go all
the way to e n these vectors these
column vectors here the set of these so
2 e 1 e 2 all the way to e n this is
called the standard basis standard basis
4rn so why is it call that well it's the
word basis is there so two things must
be true these things must span our end
and they must be linearly independent
it's pretty obvious from inspecting
they're linearly independent if this guy
has a 1 here and no one else has a 1
there there's no way you can construct
that one with some combination of the
rest of the guys and you can make that
same argument for each of the ones in
each of the components so it's clearly
linearly independent and then to see
that you can span that you can construct
any vector with a linear combination of
these guys you really just have to you
just really have to you know whatever
vector you want to construct if you want
to construct x1 let me put it this way
if you want to construct this vector if
you want to let me write it this way let
me pick a different one let's say you
want to construct the vector a1 a2 a3
all the way down to a n so this is some
member of RN you want to construct this
vector well
the linear combination that would get
you this is literally a1 times e1 plus
a2 times e2 plus all the way to a n
times en right you just this this scalar
times this first column vector will
essentially just get you what will this
look like this will look like a 1 and
then you'd have a bunch of zeros you'd
have n minus 1 zeros plus 0 and you'd
have an a2 and then you'd have a bunch
of zeros and then you keep doing that
and then you would have zeros a bunch of
zeros then you would have an a n and
obviously by our definition of vector
addition you add all of these things up
you get this guy right here and it's
kind of obvious because this right here
is the same thing as our identity matrix
times a 1 I just wanted to expose you to
that idea now let's apply what we
already know about linear
transformations to what we've just
learned about this identity matrix I
just told you that I can represent any
vector like this I can let me write it
rewrite it maybe terms of X I can write
any vector X I can write any vector X as
a linear combination of these of the
standard basis which is really just the
Kahlo
of the identity matrix oh I can write
that as x1 times a1 plus x2 times e2 all
the way to xn times en and remember each
of these column vectors right here I'd
like for a 1 is just 1 in the first come
in the first entry and then all the rest
are 0 is e 2 is a 1 in the second entry
and everything else is 0 en is or a 5 is
a 1 in the fifth entry and everything
else is 0 and this I just showed you and
this is a bit obvious from this right
here now we know that by definition a
linear transformation so if I do so a
linear transformation of X a linear
transformation of well let me put it
this way a linear transformation of X of
our vector X is the same thing as taking
the linear transformation of this whole
thing we do another color is equal to
the linear transformation of let me say
actually instead of using the T let me
use T instead of using L let me use T I
used L by accident because I was
thinking linear but if I were to take
the linear transformation of X because
that's the notation we're used to that's
the same thing as taking a linear
transformation of this thing these
they're equivalent so X 1 times e 1 plus
X 2 times e 2 all the way to plus X n
times en it's equivalent statements now
from the definition of linear
transformations we know that this is the
same thing that the transformation of
the sum is equal to the sum of the
transformation so this is equal to this
is equal to the transformation of X 1 e
1 plus the transformation of X 2 e 2
where this is just any linear
transformation let me make that very
clear this is any linear transformation
any linear transformation this is the
this by definition linear
transformations have to satisfy these
properties so the transformation times X
2 e 2 all the way to this transformation
times this last entry the scalar xn
times my standard basis vector e
and and we know from the other property
of linear transformations that the
transformation of a vector multiplied by
the scalar is the same thing is the same
thing as the scalar multiplied by the
transformation multiplied by the
transformation of the vector that's just
from our definition of linear
transformations plus x2 times the
transformation of e 2 plus all the way
that to X let me write all the way to xn
times the transformation of en now what
is this
I could rewrite this so everything I've
done so far so the transformation of X
is equal to that which I've just using
our properties of linear transformations
all linear transformations this has to
be true for them I get to this and this
is equivalent this is equal to if we
view each of these as a column vector
each of those as a column vector this is
equal to what this is equal to the
matrix where this is the first column
te1
and then the second column is T e2 and
then we go all the way to T e n times
our times let me put it this way times
x1 x2 all the way to xn we've seen this
multiple multiple times now what's
really really really neat about this is
I just started with an arbitrary
transformation and I just show that an
arbitrary transformation arbitrary
linear transformation of X can be
re-written as a product of a matrix
where I'm taking that same linear
transformation of each of our standard
basis vectors and I can construct that
matrix and multiplying that matrix times
my X vector is the same thing as this
transformation so this essentially
showing you that all transformations all
let me be careful all linear
transformations can be represented by a
it can be a matrix vector product not
only did I show you that you can do it
but it's actually a fairly
straightforward thing to do this is
actually a pretty simple op
to do let me let me show you an example
and this is what I mean I think this is
super neat let's say that I just I'm
just going to make up some
transformation let's say I have a
transformation and it's a mapping
between let's make it extra interesting
between r2 and r3 and let's say my
transformation say let's say that T of X
1 X 2 is equal to let's say the first
entry is x1 plus 3x2 the second entry is
5 x2 minus x1 and let's say the third
entry is for x1 plus x2 this is a
mapping I could have written it like
this I could write T of any vector in r2
x1 x2 is equal to maybe this is just
redundant but I think you get the idea
I like this notation better x1 plus 3x2
5 x2 minus x1 and then 4 X 1 plus X 2
this statement and this statement I just
wrote are equivalent and I like to
visualize this a little bit more now I
just told you that I can represent this
transformation as a matrix vector
product how do I do it well what I do is
I take the transformation of this guy so
what am i my domain right here is r2 and
I produce a vector that's it going to be
an RN so what I do is let's say so I'm
concerned with multiplying things times
things times vectors in r2 so what we're
going to do is we're going to start with
the identity matrix identity - because
that's my domain and it just looks like
this 1 0 0 1 I'm just going to start
with that and all I do is I apply my
transformation to each of the columns
each of my standard bases these are the
standard basis for r2 right and you
might be you know wonder what you know I
showed you that their basis how do I
know that there's 10th why do they why
do they call the standard basis and I
haven't covered this in a lot of detail
right yet but you could take the dot
product of any of these guys with the
dot product with any of the other guys
and you'll see that they're all
orthogonal to each other the dot part
any one of these columns with the other
is always zero so that's a nice clue and
they all have length of one so that's a
nice reason why they're called the
standard basis but anyway back to our
our our attempt to represent this
transformation as a matrix vector
product so we say look our domain is in
r2 so let's start with I two or ar-ar-ar
we call it our two by two identity
matrix and let's apply the
transformation to each of the its column
vectors where each of its column vectors
are a vector in the standard basis for
r2 so our stand so T of so I could so
I'm going to write it like this T of
first the first column is T of this
column and then the second column is
going to be T of 0 1 and I know I'm
getting Messier with my handwriting but
what is T of what is T of the vector 1 0
well we just go here and we construct
another vector so we get 1 plus 3 times
0 is 1 then we get 5 times 0 minus 1 so
that's minus 1 right x2 is 0 in this
case and then we get 4 times 1 plus 0 so
that's just 4 so that's T of 1 0 and
then what is T of let me T of 0 1 T of 0
1 is equal to so we have 0 plus 3 times
1 is 3 then we have 0 minus 1 is minus 1
let me make sure I did this one right
what was this this was 5 times 0 minus 1
and then now if 5 times 0 minus x1 which
is 1 now this case it's 5 times I'll
have to be careful let me this is 5
times x2 x2 is 1 so 5 times 1 minus 0 so
it's 5 and then I have 4 times 0 plus x2
plus 1
and I just showed you if I replace if I
replace each of these standard basis
vectors with the transformation of them
what do I get I get this vector right
here so I already figured out what they
are i get if i replace if I take this
guy and evaluate it it's the vector 1
minus 1 4 and then this guy is a vector
3 5 + 1 + I so what we just did and this
is I don't know I for some reason I find
this to be pretty amazing we can
renounce formation here as the product
of any vector so if we define this to be
equal to a so we could really we could
write we could write it this way we can
now write our transformation our
transformation of x1 x2 can now be
re-written as the product of this vector
I'll write it in green the vector 1 3 -
1 5 4 1 times our input vector x1 x2
which is super cool because now we just
have to do a matrix multiplication
instead of this and if we have some
processor that does this super fast we
can then use that and what's really I
don't know I think this is
it's especially elegant because what
happens here is we applied the
transformations to each of the columns
of a 2 by 2 matrix and we got a 3 by 2
matrix we got a 3 by 2 matrix and we
know what happens when you multiply 3 by
2 matrix times a vector that's in r2 or
you can almost view this as a 2 by 1
matrix you're going to get you're going
to get a vector that is in r3 right
because you're going to have these guys
times that guy is going to be the first
term these ties and these guys going to
be the second term these guys times
those guys are going to be the third
term so if I by kind of creating this 3
by 2 matrix we have actually created a
mapping from r2 to r3 anyway I for some
reason I find this to be especially neat
hopefully at least you find this
somewhat instructive